[Musique]
tél
ils y ont droit
[Musique]
voici tout le jeu spécial nuls avec
madonna erotica ne dit pas ça au csa
coup de chapeau à pascal obispo pour sa
jolie mélodie 6,6 plus le caméraman
laurent baffie et son bas fichaux la
maquilleuse chantal ladesou évadés du
théâtre grévin le super expert françois
rollin alias professeur rollin et le dj
philippe corti le meilleur du pays plus
alain chabat chantal lauby et dominique
farrugia
voici double jeu spécial les nuls
[Musique]
messieurs bonsoir bienvenue aux folies
bergères pour double je
je suis très heureux de vous retrouver
comme tous les samedis soirs pour notre
émission du samedi soir une émission qui
je l'espère vous fera réfléchir avec nos
sujets info ou intox
et vous divertir avec nos variétés donc
bienvenue pour cette soirée que nous
allons passer tous ensemble c'est nul
alors on va commencer par un mini débat
en forme d'interview parallèle c'est à
dire bien chiant je vais vous poser à
tous les trois les mêmes questions à
tour de rôle les questions qu'on vous a
déjà pesé à peu près 200 mille fois donc
accrochez vous pourquoi les nuls
terrible parce qu'on est parti
d'objectifs nul on a une parodie
d'objectifs nul
et puis dans les couloirs personne ne
connaissait trop on connait c'est
simplement l'histoire d'objectifs nul
donc un canal tout le monde disait oui
sont les nuls etc
donc c'est resté naturellement gildas a
pris le pas ouais puis après on sait
démerdé pour garder le nom quoi ouais
donc on s'appelle les nuls encore moi
j'étais pas d'accorder je pouvais jouer
ou la wba des super pour les 10 km était
déjà pris il est aller gueuler chez de
greffe le directeur les noms ça pue est
venu le ça marchera pas comme n'ont pas
traîné
alors vous êtes à vous êtes un groupe
qui a été créée artificiellement par les
par les dirigeants de canal+ qui vous a
demandé de collaborer
alors ce qui nous incite concerne moi
personnellement c'est alain de greef
fait elle et albert mathieu avec bruno
carette je travaillais sur la côte
et puis en une émission d'humour donc
nous ont demandé de venir faire des
maquettes à paris et c'est là qu'on a
rencontré sézigue ça s'est très mal
passé au départ
ouais on sent cadrait pas trop et puis
il était avec une équipe et puis voilà
jour ça fuse un mariage forcé en quelque
sort au départ puis après non ah oui
c'est un match forcément j'étais avec
deux autres potes et qui je me suis
engueulé puis après on s'est engueulé et
puis on continue à s'engueuler oui j'ai
vu au flipper je suis demandé s'il avait
du boulot il m'a pris et ça a commencé à
fonctionner quand cette affaire
et ça a marché tout de suite puisqu'on
est dans un premier set d'heure après la
sortie de machin donc les gens je me
souvient mme amos à 3,7 g t d'or c'est
un peu pour corinne et un peu du à
succès le succès nation mais vous l'avez
bien mérité
qu'est ce qui t'a guette le plus chez
eux ce qui t'énerve le plus chez les
deux là comment sont enfin au delà d un
petit truc privé pour tout de suite ça
prenne des proportions énormes il va
jouer avec ça pendant des heures et des
heures et des jours et des jours par là
ça va m'énerver sané souvent collé un
jour elle va dire par exemple
or je suis pas je sais pas un juif il me
fait chier mais toutes les deux la
traite d'antisémite semaine alors qu'il
est pas du tout antisémite et à la
serpent à lunettes c'est à dire qu'un
jour il va se lever bien virulent de mal
viré on sait jamais comment le mans mais
à côté de ça je les aime bien tous les
deux ça fait sept ans qu'on travaille
ensemble est vraiment non honnêtement je
veux pas la syrie ce qui te gonfle chez
eux c'est shabazz de kidal gbl est
toujours à la bourre total et surtout
lorsqu'on la tête régulièrement sur des
conneries genre très content du style la
feuille là je l'avais laissée là tu l'a
déplacé de 20 centimes et les modules
sont des trucs autrement j'aime tout
chez eux surtout leur art
c'est là qu'est ce qui gonfle le plus
c'est chantal par ailleurs j'ai non je
suis un petit chanteur est déchire les
craintes page pourquoi faire d espèce de
réflexe d'une main c'est super dur à
faire on a essayé en plus à la hausse ce
qui fait que tu peux pas laisser traîner
un contrat quand il ya un journal tu
sais quand elle l'a lu kouassi qui sont
déchirés c'est ça se pratique et ça ça
m'énerve énormément temps décident en
forme se sert mauvaise foi surtout moi
trés trés mauvaise un garçon de mauvaise
foi mais pas du tout
dis moi est ce que tu as déjà couché
avec un nul non non non non sincèrement
même pas un soir de tout je suis pas un
tirage un peu près ce que te dire ce qui
est étonnant c'est qu'on a jamais des
fois je me demande s'il me prenne pour
une gonzesse des fois je me dis est ce
que cette fille bon je regarde bon c'est
vrai que c'est toujours habillé en
pantalon j'essaie de m'habiller comme
j'arrive jamais avec les jupettes et
tout parce qu'on travaille au bureau on
est là comme ça ils arrivent avec leur
gîte moi aussi c'est vrai qu'on n'est
pas quand même des modèles d'élégance
donc on a vraiment des rapports moi je
considère un peu bon c'est vrai c'est
pareil durer un petit jeu sympa l'idée
j'aurais l'impression sera incestueux
toi non plus pareil tu veux pas non plus
non bien sûr jamais eu envie je sais pas
je les subis mais soirée qui orne agen
peut crever comme ça non non non non
bien sûr que non non ne s'est jamais
passé ça m'aidait des canules s'arrête
si tu as fait tu me dire hey toi oui
mais je sais qu'il ya probablement plein
de plein de gens qui s'imaginent des
choses et les inconnus ses skis contre
eux du coup si je pense
vie contre le noir et l'autre là le gros
point noir il n'y a pas de gros shebab
ont déserté
quel temps nul préférées j'ai paniqué
préféré gmc des groupes
je vais dire honnêtement c'est du foot
la machine en jaune est vrai que nono
bruno c'était mon pote depuis depuis pas
mal de temps ça faisait 10 12 ans qu'on
se connaissait donc c'est vrai que
c'était on était on travaille ensemble
antibes on est venu à paris ensemble et
tout donc c'est vrai que c'était
quelqu'un de très proche mais c'est vrai
que on a eu des moments durs ensemble et
du moment merveilleux ça nous a
vachement rapprocher les aime tous les
deux
chabal du doigts de large en ce moment
alors c'est tant mieux et toi que ton
nul préféré un enjeu de seconde cette
remarque
ah bon au cap a en fait il pas
d'histoires entre vous quoi il n'y a pas
de problème non c'est ça le drame
ben on s'arrête on va demander à
françois rollin professeur rollin
secourir resituer le débat s'il vous
plaît mon pauvre thierry quoi mon pauvre
tirer vraiment vous me faites pitié la
chercher des scandales et des bruits de
chiottes pour faire de l'audimat mais
mon pauvre animée qu'est ce que j'en ai
à secouer mais l'animal mais moi si les
gens s'intéressent pas à ce que je fais
une occase ap allez-y sap et qu'est ce
que j'en ai à [ __ ] ma toute façon
c'est le service public ici c'est payé
d'avancé on n'a pas besoin d'eau dit il
avait déjà payé la redevance alors si
vous n'êtes pas contents ça paie barrez
vous allez
sur tf1 il ya une chose à y insérer
format dat
dion sur m6 un film sur canal il ya des
documentaires fabuleuse ap restait pas
là foutez nous la paix a regardés comme
des idiots la halle et les api ya trop
de gens pour moi encore encore les
balles dum barrez-vous bon ya trop de
monde
thierry reprenait l'émission c'est le
meilleur moyen de faire baisser l'audi
m
au mr shabbat à yahvé rapide si use the
lovely décor aux folies bergère oui je
parle en anglais c'est la langue qui
comprend depuis dix ans explique toutes
ces idées à télévision américaine tient
bien mais ayew stalingrad yupiks du riz
des américains tv qui aura eu cette idée
naquit to be - bon chantal oui je me
bats
c'est vrai que tu que les idées à tout
va bien si non alors appât pour le dire
dis moi tu es né à alger à oran à oran
oran donc vous en algérie tu as passé
son enfance à à pacy non j'ai passé mon
enfance à massy pis il pas grave quand
tu étais petit donc tu voulais être
aviateurs cessa pompiers exactement
parce que j'aime le saut c'est un truc
qui j'aime le feu ouais tu vas te
pompiers pas et quand tu ça arrivait
bien alors un jour donc tu tues tu
voulais dessiner une bd qui se passait
dans une radio et c'est comme ça que tu
es rentré à radio monte carlo c'est
comme ça que oui ça exact mais moi je
veux faire une bd avec un lieu quoi donc
c'était bien lieu n'est pas un héros de
sa radio andorre que tu es rentré
imbéciles assez radio andorre pas raison
c'est un viol
mais c'est pas grave c'est pas grave et
immédiat était passée il avait appelé la
du mont d'or j'espère durable et puis et
puis un jour donc tu décides de faire
une bd qui se passait dans une radio
radio et tu rentres comme ça à radio
monte-carlo radio andorre scélérate du
sud pendant la dent avec artie parreira
et c'est là après à l'oreille en coin
que tu as rencontré pierre lescure non à
l'oreille en coin
j'ai rencontré franck adrian wells qui
je faisais l'oreille en coin un essai
après à rmc où j'ai rencontré pierre
lescure et a fait le rayon quoi ouais
non
de quoi aller taffer les trucs sur les
politiques et tous j'ai fait un mois les
aventures de deux de deux mecs qui
écoutait la radio on voit tu me l'a
jamais dit pas ce que je dis là et
étaient passés donc après sur canal tout
à fait les infos j'ai fait de la météo à
la météo était donc monsieur météo de
canal au début vent qui la suite on le
la suite on la connaît l'histoire
devenue tu as trois enfants et j'ai deux
enfants j'ai deux filles depuis deux
petites filles
alors moi aussi tu en es content et très
grande absente où la plupart commencent
à rendre service à sa mère la plus
grande et la petite elle fait chier tu
as acheté une ferme dans le lubéron dans
en normandie en normandie
ok je vois que tu veux pas mais dès la
gestion cdg veut pas mêler les td ce que
je te dis tu dis non merci
voilà excuse moi on va passer la promo
alors parce que je vois que sur la vie
personnelle une excuse moi alors le on a
fait une émission de la semaine dernière
pour parler de la promo sur antenne 2
bons qu'à trouver l'argent nous on s'en
fout c'est france 2 france oui c'est 500
balles quand on dit antennes ne savent
pas si si je savais vous voulez donner
tout de suite le pognon non non je ferai
après avec laurent gerra sera donc le 20
novembre sort chez albin michel
un livre qui s'appelle l'info c'est
rigolo oui a dit pas le contraire
c'est un livre très très bien et coûtent
pas cher là pendant qu'on parle parle un
peu parce que pour l'instant il ya le
livre qui apparaît en gros sur l'écran
d'accord d'accord c'est formidable
formidable chez albin michel crépu
sédition même le prix vous fera rire 300
pages de bêtises pour 99 cents balles
doit cesser temps d'information mis dans
un même match et un livre entièrement
original non non c'est une compil amer
nous on n'a rien fait mais dans tout
compiler et albin michel a compilé alors
à part ça vous êtes tous les trois tous
les matins sur europe 1 sur europe 2
donc entre 7h et 9h pas mal pas loin et
puis elle filme enfin pas le film que
vous devez écrire de ce que je suis là
vous n'êtes pas un instant que vous
allez tous là on tourne tourne
normalement au printemps on me montre
l'été on mixe l'été il sort dans l'antre
septembre et décembre 93 30 93 votre
réseau et il faut qu'il soit écrit
pourquoi on pour arriver à tenir zone de
leasing le 22 décembre un mérite d'être
précis clair vous en êtes page 3 back to
back aujourd'hui on a écrit bateau d'une
très belle écriture alors puis un autre
film en fait celui qui sort maintenant
white world
sinon vous avez écrit l'adaptation mais
c'est un très gros carton aux usa c'est
vrai même carton en france en faisant un
bon ballon dedans c'est bien marché à
une bonne première semaine avant le
final et vendeurs c'est un film
barresi c'est ton interview bon bah
c'est un c'est un film américain avec
avec deux crétins qui s'appelle dana
carvey et qui est un acteur formidable
et je garde qui a les cheveux longs et
des lunettes et mike myers qui a écrit
le film que voilà et ce qui ressemble un
peu à manoeuvre et simon temps il va me
tuer parce qu'il aime pas tous viennent
pas le film et voila c et d pour les
crétins qui aiment le hard rock il faut
être très bien moi quand même entre 8 et
14 ans plus tard au dessus tu peux te
faire un peu siégé tout conclut veut
dire j'étais assis à côté de faire ta
tuque ont pris un film c'est facile quoi
c'est un peu pour les bas du front mais
c'est agréable on s'en sort sans vous
avez fait quoi vous avez fait
l'adaptation en fait la promo on l'a
fait on a fait tout l'adaptation cyr
qu'ils avaient du mal à traduire
certains gags y avait des fausses pubs
des trucs était vraiment très très
américain donc ils nous ont appelés en
nous disant tenez regardez ce film et
dites nous si vous avez envie de bosser
dessus nous on arrête on est allés tous
les deux ça m'a fait marrer c'est en vo
non sous-titrée
on a compris un peu répond à ta place
lui je ne crois pas et moins chiant coin
il a raison ils veulent et c'est toi qui
me regarde tu me pose une question
autrement
ces deux heures personne lui derrière
c'était c'était aux yeux pardon excusez
je vous à rapporter combien cette
affaire ça nous a rapporté une somme
difficilement concevable pour un esprit
moins
ouais mais tu es très très bien fait
j'ai un pourcentage d'au dessus non plus
n'a pas pour ça c'est parce qu'on n'a
pas pris de pourcentage à l'appel des
verts a souhaité même un peu gêné mais
bon c'est de l'ordre
c'est de l'ordre de beaucoup avant
j'étais dans le brut bah voilà on va
regarder un extrait du film prenez votre
petit télévisa bout de terre
pour elle mme wang et le dernier
p2 julio frenk of china
[Musique]
et
ce qui est semé alors j'ai une surprise
pour vous enfin pas pour toi parce que
tu as tout en époque du fait de ce film
j'ai une surprise pour vous c'est
l'acteur leblanc là bas servette mois à
lui ouais non mais ne riez pas encore si
tu as dit à l'époque
ouais
notre vie famous people in france adapté
dieu you move et fort france
c'est la première fois que tu me parles
envie d'y aller
incroyable alors tu es prêt on va passer
aux questions qu'on pas d'accord devant
en effet c'est ok d'accord t'es prêt là
mais pour répéter la question est ce que
tu préfères staline ou hitler
ça fait plaisir de prendre hitler parce
que je me serais plus con c'est tu dois
partir de 3 ans dans un vaisseau spatial
tpr est là tu préfères day hervé vilard
ou patrick juvet comprendre d'eux comme
ça il s'occupe
il préférait faire l'amour avec une
fille très très très laide ou un mec
très très très beau je suis très très
très laide ah bon quand même
oui à lui les mecs s'était jamais arrivé
en plus acquis trouves-tu le plus de
circonstances atténuantes jacques pradel
un vieux qui se tape des petites ou un
jeune qui tapent sur des vieilles des
petites de quel âge à peu près 12 13 en
quoi ce présent les biches landou
[ __ ] 20 jeunes qui tapent sur une
vieille dans la vie de la vieille a déjà
été fait
elle a eu déjà des joueurs tandis que la
jeune tu l'unique tout de suite à 12 ans
étaient ces questions cons mais c'est
bien sûr non mais c'est bien c'est bien
donc disons ça disons l'avion le mot le
plus con en amour
merci encore oui oui merci merci merci
si tu penses à dire pendant dix ans
questions choisies pas de bouffe ou pas
de cul à un jeu tu dises panne de pâtes
bluff fait bouffer est un droit de
bouffer le cube c'est pour ça que j'ai
hésité à écarter
mais je compte y est tu bouges pas
beaucoup alors que tu prends pas de
bouffée pas de but ouais ouais
mathis qq sinon ouais ouais d'accord tu
préfères être réincarné en bergers
allemands un setter irlandais ou
épagneul breton web berger allemand un
jour un boulot plus un berger allemand
joue peut-être je suis berger allemand
de l'asie je lui mord les couilles la
bombe arrive dans 5 minutes tu fais quoi
je continue interview je suis un
professionnel
il était possible
est-ce que tu accepterais d'échangés toi
d'échanger une paralysie générale contre
la faim de la faim en somalie et au
soudan et au souhait au soudan elle est
le mal il ya lieu par est allé au mali
allait tuer paralysé jusqu'à la fin de
tes jours allongée sur un lit légumes
il existe des gens là mangent à leur
faim d'accord pas en coupant dans tout
le temps tout le temps tout le temps
mais ya toujours des impôts en france
avec que la fin la somalie le soudan et
le mali non ce jeu tu veux pas non je
continue à courir et jouer
il y en at il et au nahd il fera jamais
de politique en renard pas un fauteuil
préfèrerais mourir comme en rayon laser
bombe à neutrons ou gaz hinault 2 c'est
bien c'est tout bien la marque
ouais donc norway n'importe quoi je m'en
fous un rayon laser ça fait impossible
et en laser sait comment il meurt
lahdjar ou non tu avais un perroquet
chez toi tu lui apprendrait d'affaires
mais le gaz tu as pensé à la capote ou
coco arrête là coco tu as pensé à la
cathode à penser à la cape facture à un
perroquet qui dirait ça voilà est-ce que
tu préfèrerais toutes avaient le choix
est reclus chat ou un puissant jet comme
ça j'ai des collègues qui traînent pas
très très bien donc tu préférerais qu'on
est impuissant non non si c'est possible
je resterai pas bon ça va s'arranger
quoique quoique pour les impuissants
maintenant il ya un truc tu prends ton
petit téléviseur dire que et regarde
c'était un enchaînement pour lutter
contre le stress dans l'entreprise tous
les moyens sont bons des catalogues
spécialisés dans la vente d'articles de
bureau propose de drôles d'objets aux
cadres dynamiques sujet au petit coup de
barre sexuelle un appareil discret qui
stimule des érections grâce à un champ
magnétique alternatif
il ya des appareils qui sont proposées
aujourd'hui pour guérir entre guillemets
les troupes de direction en particulier
des appareils utilisant les ondes
électromagnétiques ne nous paraissent
pas convaincante
si c'était le cas ça se saurait et on
aurait distribué le prix nobel à son
inventaire voici le coupable le bio
poteau or si petit il se glisse dans la
poche du pantalon les organisations
féministes pour immédiatement réagi
l'objet j'imagine doit être vendu dans
tout les sex-shops je dirais puis ça
fait partie des comportements sexuels
privé de tout un chacun
le problème de savoir c'est pourquoi il
est dans un bain dans un catalogue de
matériel de bureau et il nous semble que
dans un contexte où où il ya tout de
même énormément de harcèlement sexuel et
d'agression sexuelle
cela pose véritablement un réveil est un
problème tant que c'est un objet qui
facilite la masturbation n'y a aucun
problème à partir moment où il est vendu
dans un temps d'une publication de
bureau ça pose le problème du rapport
entre la personne qu'ils utilisent
encore le voici temps texte je vois pas
eu d'escroquerie et l'environnement de
travail et coûté à tomber je veux le
sortir de la poche parce que ça fait
quand même la deuxième prise et ça fait
lui l'objet dans la poche mais je peux
vous dire que toujours
espérons que le bio potter est efficace
car pour un rapide moment de détente au
bureau l'autre solution plus
scientifique est proche de la torture
il y a toujours bien sûr la méthode
psychologique
mais la véritable révolution aujourd'hui
c'est l'injection directement dans la
verge d'une drogue tels que la
prostaglandine qui va faciliter
l'érection et ce de façon certaine
ouais ouais
pour provoquer des élections s de l'info
de l'intox
je vous le demande maintenant pendant
que vous réfléchissez chez vous enfin
que nous réfléchissons ici qu'est ce
qu'on écoute parti parti à parti
c'est en plein ce soir alors je te
propose quelque chose de bien mieux que
la version originale c'est chabal et
dominique faruggia dans qu'est ce que tu
vends pour les vacances
des tiges des gangs
mais dont on sait qu'on
ça
on vendait au même endroit tu devrais
santa
sur les quatre mois
je tenais
sur les parfums
[Musique]
qu'est-ce que tu vends pour les vacances
les garçons
myfab
je ne
je pense un peu en avance a nouvelle
mais
chez réarrangés pour les vacances
[Musique]
je
un peu en avance à l'ouverture 2
au magasin
même ça a toujours marché vous
à
tél
moi j'en ai
par les tongiens
en mal de sentiments
qu'est ce que tu veux
vacances
les gazons
emma
ben
je ne serais je pense un peu en avance
mais turtur maga
j'ai plus rien entre et 43
mais souhaite
je
mais je crois 1
henry tourneux
btb un article de bureau pour provoquer
des érections s de l'info s de la tête
chantal à toi de répondre moi je pense
que c'est de l'intox
je vois pas un article de bureaux où
justement on est en train de parler de
harcèlement sexuel elle avait raison la
dame j'imagine comme ça maintenant ça se
paie aussi on a fait tout pour attirer
clients c'est un bon moyen qu'est ce
qu'il ya au niveau je veux dire c'est s
excuse moi mais qu'est-ce qu'il a rien
du tout j'avais tout je trouve je trouve
que c'est pas une raison je viens parce
que tu es nul que tout d'un coup poser
des questions ou si nul que ça c'est nul
je directeur staline mais enfin tu
réponds pas tout le monde islamique avec
un truc ça va maintenant il faut se
calmer
là j'en avais dit à thierry j'étais pas
bien un message la pose d'un toit mais
les ccc nul dit qu'il allait me la poser
au moment de cette question est ce que
tu préfères ton père et ta mère hitler
staline où l on va justement moi tu me
pose pas la question est ce que tu vas
faire ton père ta mère staline allez on
y va avec son gros de cette émission
arrête gérard enfin on fait une émission
de télé je sais bien c'est lui c'est son
truc lui l'a déjà fait ces de chavannes
c'est un truc ça tu t'es vu le faire
chez dechavanne
c'est un grand truc d'arriver dans les
émissions de télé mais j'écrivais saguez
ghana puis jeté des chaises mais j'étais
déjà vu le faire une
on a parlé aussi l'hérault
hantée savatan oui les serviettes jeu
l'est déjà non ça va juste comme par
hasard tu tellement de conneries que tu
peux pas le laisser parler ses
incroyables attend lui c'est son truc tu
deviens les émissions ouais ok non mais
ça je me mêle pas si ton truc
allez on va les mettre bastille je le
crois pas a lui la vie voilà d'une
émission de télé les gens de bouquins
aussi faut comprendre le bouquet de
kenzy piot merde tu crois que c'est
parce que tu veux dire trois conneries
avec prendre un homme à deux questions à
la con qui te tiens tu ne bougez vous
torchis cavada comme à d'abord par
exemple tu ok mais tu mets toi là ok ça
cinq minutes là puisque tu voulais
partir becqueter avec eux
ok 28 mai l'appui à la fin de l'émission
moi je te parle je te jure que ça je
t'emmène dans le confessionnal situes tu
me poses dans le confessionnal bah ouais
mais j'étais jeune et de confesser
vraiment augmenté à la première fois
ouais se voit la première fois j'aime
raconter pourquoi tu viens dans les
émissions de télé ayant levé satisfaire
le chef d'état ne t'énerve pas bon et
c'est un conte bien comme sur la télé ça
devient si fausse quatre bus est
d'accord mais bravo la porte 1 ok alors
on reprend sur des aplombs s'il vous
plaît
est-ce de l'intro ans thierry gabriel
qui frappent à la porte par exemple
c'est la soirée we dit qu'il attend de 5
minutes sûrs parce qu'on familiale crois
pas chantal alors c'est de l'info [ __ ]
intox bon à tôtes hockey à toi ci
dessous c'est de l'info c'est de l'info
c'est sûr c'est un fossile et rue pour
demander au bureau c'est normal c'est
plus personne pour des blues alors mal
je connais qui disent que c'est de la
loire d'accord c'est de l'info c'est de
l'info ou alors elle joue très bien et
comédienne il faut les engagés c'est de
l'info moi je regarde que la forme j'ai
coûte rien aux textes rien juste la
forme
ouais j'ai plein de français mais ce
qu'on a tourné que des comédiens qui
jouent des voitures privées
c'est un sujet qui nous a été envoyé par
monsieur eric barreau d'ezanville qui
gagne 2000 francs je t'attends déçu
raison ville en partie gagné le feront
parce que son sujet a déjà été tourné
gagne deux mille fois parce que son
sujet étaient maintenant pour savoir si
je rajoute me sort de ma poche de maple
on écoute la réponse effectivement dans
le catalogue du bureau moderne parmi
d'autres objets parmi d'autres
fournitures de bureau et proposer un
appareil appelé le bio pet ensor censé
améliorer la capacité sexuelles ainsi
que la puissance notre assistante a
testé le bio potter sort sur l'équipe de
tournage voici le résultat sur le
preneur de sons le journaliste et le
caméraman
écrit et dames et messieurs je tiens bio
pauthe ensor pour mettre dans votre
petite poche pour aller au bureau
toi tu perds ton pays tant pis enfin
c'est un peu désolant beaux jours en
perspective
ouais et où deux donc c'est imbattable
là dessus corti le score a bien ri on
constate une fois de plus que chantal au
niveau rection elle comprend rien du
tout alors que youtube et nous munich
marque un point dans le cube
dominique jacquet maintenant chantal
lauby à l'écossé
ouais
le chantage et j'aimerais vous dire à
vos votre film la formidable ainsi fin
drôle subtil profond j'ai adoré 1 puis
la média marché vingt mille entrées la
première semaine un super vaincre lui a
tout remis à chantal le film s'il n'est
pas encore sorti c'est un projet leur
film je parlais one world
ah bon vous êtes si oui ah bon alors
j'essaie rabon j'ai adoré quand même
votre projet si si j'ai vraiment adoré
mes affiches merci merci
[Applaudissements]
chantal
alors je crois que entre nous deux ça
devrait mieux se passer qu'avec alain
chabat va tu es né en auvergne
ouais tu vois déjà non c'est pas une
auberge allez au diable chine à gap mais
c'est vrai que j'aime et qui auvergnat
est d'accord et du torride yen a aussi
jeté une ferme à côté de la maison de sa
grand-mère où tu avais passé de si
merveilleusement commencé petit à petit
tout tu vois c'est ça ouais je suis
content l'âge est très content ensuite
tu as eu une adolescence
ouais comme tout le monde sauf que la
tienne elle était ici n'est rente
ouais j'ai reçu des pansements presque
vagabonde parce que ton père était
militaire l'a fait ce que tu sais vous
reconnaître les galons sur l'unique
n'entend pas du tout pas du tout bon il
faisait quoi ton papa il était dans la
gamme dans la gendarmerie mobile il
avait pas de gallons le pauvre et ça lui
plaisait tellement son boulot qu'il en
est tombé malade et puis bon il a arrêté
non et dis moi pourquoi tu me parles de
pansements non parce que je crois qu'il
parlait des pansements que tu m'as dit
une vie vagabonde c'est vrai que j'ai
vendu des pansements pendant un an quand
j'ai bon c'était mon premier boulot
j'étais tombé sur un mec que j'aimais
bien et qui vendait des pansements
américain et puis je suis partie vendue
fait le tour de la france avec tous mes
copains on était une vingtaine on
vendait des pansements et l'argent en
porte à porte en clair ont claqué tout
le soir quand je crois que tu me parler
de ça non non non non non c'était ton
papa et ensuite tu as commencé donc à
faire de la radio dans le midi oui la
télévision télévision
c'est ça jusque là non ouais c'est ça
qui se réfèrent 3
faire 3 côte d'azur d'azur est tout à
fait j'étais présentatrice à la télé
après j'étais animatrice à la radio puis
après je rencontre bruno et puis tous
les deux on a fait on va voir
tu vois on serait tous soyez maintenant
les bienvenus sur des portants côte
d'azur j'espère que vous avez passé une
très bonne journée
il est maintenant l'heure de suivre vos
actualités télévisées régional et ce
soir c'est jean françois téaldi qui vous
présente les principales informations
voyons ensemble les principaux titres
[Musique]
vie voilà c'est avec ces images ce que
nous allons nous quitter ce soir on se
retrouve jasper veux m'asseoir à 19h20
sur les trois chaînes pour d'autres
informations télévisées régional merci
de nous avoir prêté attention ça les
brugnons s'amuse chantal vous pouvez
donc nous envoyer vos cassettes fr3 côte
d'azur afin de participer prochainement
à zurich chantal ce soir spécial thierry
mathieu zec c'est un monsieur qui marche
très bien et qui est bien et inversons
de notre région il s'appelle dan de rome
den de rome on va le découvrir tout de
suite
est-ce de la presse d'apple oui c'est
moi bien sûr c'est quoi et alors bon tu
ferais bien on n'a pas toujours fait de
zaoui et là au festival télé de monte
carlo donc tu étais avec bruno à ce
moment là vous allez rencontrer albert
mathieu et alain de greef et ils vous
ont demandé une cassette
c'est pas voulu leur donner de cela ne
m'a dit qu'une avec vous aviez peur qui
vous la rendre partiellement
quant à nous on dit et on leur a montré
ce qu'on visait non pas ça c'était pas
ça c'est que j'aurais surtout de suite
il serait pas fait c'est comme des fous
mais on ne faisait une émission d'humour
et c'est vrai quand on leur a montré
ils l'ont regardé jusqu'au bout et la
fin ils m'ont dit vous en dit vous
pouvez laisser la cassette
comment y en avait une seule on a dit
non non je suivis deux parties taper
avec d'antenne 2 à l'époque en disant
voilà on fait une émission d'humour est
ce que vous êtes intéressé à ce moment
là je vais un mec foncé me dire mais
attention au canal si on vrai qu'ils
sont intéressés
donc voilà c'est venu comme ça mais
sinon c'est vrai j'y croyais pas bondues
moi toutes ces conneries on s'en fout au
fond gens s'en foutent complètement mon
sens je vous en achetez un drôle un peu
tu es marié non ah bon non mais pas
mariés mais tu as des enfants donc c'est
une petite fille à laquelle elle achète
plus de neuf ans elle s'appelle comment
jennifer est pourquoi on entend jamais
parler du père fou quoi je parle du père
personnes me pose des questions sur lui
mais moi je compose mes arguments
possibles ben voilà le papa je suis avec
lui depuis deux ans mais de la
télévision
et là il a honte parce que tu dis des
gros mois la tva non coutume fesci alain
tu vois je t'avais dit je sois non mais
c'est pas grave je vais dire on ne sait
pas grave mais bon c'est la sécurité
ces trucs j'ai pas envie d'aller parler
du terme annoncés ce soir entre armand
et non mais c'est vrai que c'est un peu
lourd quand même depuis tout à l'heure
avec tes conneries sur les nazis
m'attend sur chantal l'émission elles
vont coller l'émission savais pas que
vous avez pas trop de priver ces radios
paris maintenant il ya l'autre qui
arrivent là elle qu écrire moi non mais
moi je veux bien parler de tout mais bon
six mois plus ici c'est sous jacent
c'est la paix
bah alors j'avais dit qu'il fallait pas
la faire enfin non c'est toi qui voulais
la faire au début parce que ce n'est pas
la peine non non pas pour le début on a
fait passer toi qu attends ta vie
chantal c'est tout écoutons là on va
faire autre chose je vous propose un
truc tu veux bien
il saura pas s'engueuler non je te poser
des questions tu vas répondre par oui ou
par non
six cents par message permet par exemple
alors imaginons je parle pas du père de
ta fille parce que je vais pas de
salades comme tout à l'heure si tu le
tromper si tu te trompes et est ce que
tu lui direz mais c'est une idée toi
c'est pas bon je comprends maintenant
maintenant je dirai pas si je lui dirai
pas je trouve qu'en plus ça détourne
enfin bon c'est aussi le plaisir de
tromper si je disais ouais tu penses que
si tu dis pas d'accord qu'ils aient
compris est-ce que tu passes à la 12è
subir est-ce que tu qui traite ou pour
le grand amour non mais c'est clair au
moins maintenant non non j'ai déjà
rencontré dix fois grand amour j'ai
jamais un kit est d'accord d'accord
est ce que tu t'es ça dépend des jours
et comment je me lève si je me suis
couché par la veille et là tout de suite
je semaine des as tu te mets là sur ce
jeu mais bien sûr ce coup de gueule
parce que je vois que journée quoi un
temps assez clair est ce que tu as des
rapports sexuels dans le noir dans
l'ombre de la paix nos besoins de la
lumière
même s'il veut faire porter des armes et
par nock qu'elle veut oui non oui non
pardon dans quoi dans la lumière non
dans la pénombre oui mais tu vois on y
arrive on dirait est ce que tu fais
l'amour ailleurs que dans un lit oui je
veux pas eu dix ans parce que c'est
facile de faire la télé est ce que tu
vois il a même fait dans un lit souvient
avant c'est à dire je danse avec le
livre dès que j'ai même connu très tard
je vous ai toujours sur le mur du balcon
il m'a dit c'est possible dans indigènes
est-ce que tu le vis des revues pornos
non j'aime pas chose pas les acheter je
dire honnêtement j'ose pas rentrer dans
un magasin match et des revues pornos
suis pas de copains qui vend prête il se
les gardent toujours plus c'est pareil
elle a toujours au bureau assurée par ne
sont pas du porno c'est pas ses pulsions
d'être cédé à la pulsion j'adore parce
que plus il va moisir d'expulsion là
dans cette ville tor magazine ça va
c'est une science c'est pas mal ça soit
cela par des mecs baccino froide
procurer est-ce que tu regardes des
cassettes pornos non je regarde de temps
en temps j'ai vu des films quand tu es
un coup c'est les films pornos sur canal
au bout d'un moment ça m'énerve j'aime
pas l'éclairage est ce que tu peux tout
faire si tu aimes oui non non non non et
tombe bien j'avais besoin de réconfort
ben c'est qu'ils chassent et baffie non
c'est pas ça beats et beach art je te le
dis est ce que tu as déjà fait l'amour à
plusieurs
non c'est sûr de nom car view pas ce
qu'est ce que tu as dit qu'est ce que tu
es allé dans un peep show ben c'est
comme les revues pornos pousse pas y
aller j'y suis allé une fois avec bruno
pour tu t'es même pas peep show c'était
un sex-shop c'est pas la même chose
peep show c'est la menace des habits
super des fois elles sont déjà
planifiées
avec des foyers sont deux gars c'est
spécial parce tu mets le pognon il ya le
truc problème quand tu fais de la télé
que mais les vingt balles début ses
parents nous parents très bon est ce que
tu as déjà eu des expériences
homosexuelles non dans la pratique non
mais je me souviendrai expliqué à 17 ans
je me souviens avoir vu une fille enfin
c'était je crois que c'est un garçon
dans une boîte et en fait c'est une
fille mais ressemble étrangement un
garçon et c'est vrai que j'étais troublé
par elle j'ai essayé de faire sa
connaissance etc mais jamais j'ai
concrétisé un trou comme os fonctionne
mais je ne désespère pas ça tue le
regrette une certaine aura pas m'aider
se sont pas privés j'aime beaucoup la
compagnie des femmes tu as déjà eu des
expériences sado-maso physiques n'ont
d'ailleurs pas besoin d'aller mettre une
culotte en latex et m'accrocher un
radiateur mais c'est vrai que dans les
rapports souvent les rapports amoureux
sont des rapports sado maso j'ai bien
établir ce genre de rapport ben c'est un
peu ce que tu as fais là est-ce que tu
avais déjà exactement diensten sexe
c'est à dire voir un mec avoir envie de
baiser tout voilà comme de moi j'ai
besoin d'avoir non j'ai besoin de sentir
des choses fortes avec quelques ajouts
une romantique moi je peux pas aller
baiser comme ça en fermant les yeux en
disant enfuis non non pensez vous
on arrive donc oui oui est-ce que tu
ferais un film porno c'était un très
très grand réalisateur
non non ça j'avais fini claire arrête le
temps qui parle du jour est dans un film
porno pour combien temps 0 tu jouais
pour s'arranger
est-ce que tu jouais là lorsque tu sois
son lit
un million non un milliard mais
j'arriverai pas comment tu veux que je
fasse je pense à nous d'autres qui n'ont
pas acheté de nouveaux fonds de l'oie
géant autour des comme ça alors on se
sait pas françoise il ya ça à faire faux
jeton si je dis non mais
imaginez un mec qui voilà qui dit miller
je l'apprends canyon que les islamistes
sont situés à l'intérieur parce que
j'aimerais de propre en moi et je me dis
bon cet argent qu est ce que je ferai
avec 10 milliards si toute ma vie quand
je me regarde dans la glace fils me suis
fait trombine et devant tout le monde
avec des mecs dont j'ai pas envie ça
m'intéresse bon mois pour 10 milliards
si c'est pas un film homo je veux bien
est-ce qu alors est ce que tu aimerais
l'amour avec charles pasqua pour 10
millions n'ont pas sympa lui le prévoit
son milieu sans vision mais j'aime bien
pasqua
bien déjà serait la présente faire
l'amour avec fernandel pour 100 millions
la sphère effet très n'ont pas fait je
crois du tout non non je te dis l'argent
mais c'est ma seule phase
il fera ses commissions tous ces
analyses quoi la prochaine fois on trop
dit plus est-ce que tu as lu le rouge et
le noir
on ya longtemps mehrjoui non j'ai dû
lire honnêtement je m'en rappelle plus
bon est-ce que tu as lu le rose et le
vert et bibliothèque rose est un livre
qui s'appelle le rose et le vert a dit
non tu n'as pas lu le rosé de faire quoi
vers le court tu en prends ton petit
téléviseur et regarde en river il passe
son enfance chez son grand père dans
cette maison du centre de grenoble
plus tard ce grand voyageur devenu
consul publie sous le nom de stendhal le
rouge et le noir
ce roman paraît le 13 novembre 1830
pendant sept ans stendhal parcours alors
la campagne française il souhaite créer
une oeuvre qui fassent concurrence au
rouge et le noir
il trouve alors son héros après julien
sorel ce sera à mina avant jane une
jeune allemande et son titre le rose et
le vert ou le rouge nous ne savons pas à
ce que j'avais dit l'échec celle à
couvrir mais le bel était la couleur des
légitimistes sur luis filipe et par
conséquent il y avait là il n'a pas
l'air politique suive a l'habitude
sandales aimant jouer sur l'opposition
des couleurs stendhal a aussi écrit
l'amarante et le noir le rouge et le
blanc bien qu'inachevé le rose et le
vert a été publié après la mort de
stendhal par les éditions le castor
astral
roger levert s de l'info est de l'intox
vous vous le demandez le aux 6es de la
fox danse et de l'intox et castres
castor astral
ouais c'est mamie sur la bourse ouais
bien c'est de l'intox c'est écrit
préface henri sannier était plus près
donc c'est de l'intox et toi aussi c'est
de l'intox
parce qu'ils sont dit que j'étais
d'accord donc maintenant c'est de
l'intox et de la personne c'est un sujet
qui nous a été envoyé par monsieur
christian villard denis ce monsieur
villar a déjà gagné 2008 font ça c'est
simple pourquoi est ce qu'il a gagné
2000 francs est ce que c'est parce que
je sens déjà été joué pour nous voilà
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
voilà malheureusement il va gagner que
deux mille francs alors question la
réponse s'il vous plaît ce n'est pas une
blague de potache le rose et le vert de
stendhal ça existe bien on l'a sorti en
90 on la tire à 4000 exemplaires
ça fait partie d'une collection les
inattendus aux éditions du castor astral
dans laquelle nous publions des textes
un surprenant d'auteur extrêmement
connue
oh
alors ça ça nous était pas arrivé depuis
le premier ministre croate qui est
français et on avait la bouvard majax
elizabeth teissier qui avait rien vu
bien qu'elle soit voyante et vous quel
quand même des spécialistes la
littérature française du 19e faut bien
élevé il s'appelle sani je suis sur le
mec qui a fait la préface ses préfaces h
sagnier théorie oui et le castor astral
et catastrophe ça existe vraiment yakari
blue magic voilà voilà donc le rose et
le vert de stendhal monsieur villard
gagne donc 3000 francs
mais ce qui l'attend et chantelle le big
or si le score est pas plus que les
couleurs l'érection ne convient à
chantal lauby qui reste à 0 alors que
farruggia et puis mon cher chabat reste
aussi à eux
m
qui paye très très bientôt public toi
aussi comme ces 200 bateaux sans fil et
250 à l'émission ouais c'est la farine à
2,3 je connais assez bien
donc tu sais que maintenant nous
arrivons à un moment très important dans
cette émission
ouais donc non je ne savais pas que ça
allait mal an le bas fichaux à sa
j'adore
tu adores ouais ça me fait vraiment
beaucoup vers cette cce à les trucs les
plus drôles à la télévision en ce moment
mais dit non non c'est vrai je suis les
guignols de l'info avec les guignols
c'est ce qui est à dieu et c'est pas
poursuit c'est un grand plus on a déjà
su c'est là il est clair qu'ils se
droguent
la preuve c'est la première fois que ça
puisque d'ormesson soit il est bien sûr
des fois que voilà non mais moi je
trouve ça toujours bien bon ben ça va le
faire mais cela non
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
que pensez-vous des nuls est nul ça
super si le dos je suis du doubs
d'où cette douce du doubs vous êtes d'où
je suis de do i do do we je suis doux
que pensez-vous des nuls à besançon le
dos je passe sans qu'on passe et il
s'attend pas vu les nuls à besançon ils
sont là sur le plateau ils vous
regardent de nous excuser une question à
poser une longue c'est super ça touche
des voix sur canal c'est super ça tout
lui poser une question
on a mis le satellite blaireaux de en
haute lande ce qu'il fait beau la loi
sur le plateau alors fait bonsu plateau
de dos chabat trop que ta question est
lamentable 1
des quoi des nuls
s'ils sont nulles gens pensent à rien
non mais vous les connaissez quoi les
nuls
je ne sais pas vous parler d'une
personne ou quoi si vous parlez d'une
personne passer les nuls
frahlia qu'elle se débrouille moi
personnellement les nuls j'en ai
rencontré pas mal que je suis un
aventurier j'ai frotté aux karim on n'en
voit pas mal dans les nues lit-on dans
tout les travers possibles et
imaginables
c'est l'alcool in shadow rock c'est pas
mal de choses il s'avoue farrugia
pourquoi farrugia je connais pas vous
parlez de l'alcoolisme
oui bah oui parce que j'en ai j'en ai
hébergé pas mal chez moi et farrugia si
vous voulez si vous êtes appelé comme ça
moi je viens et chabat vous en avez eu
aussi
je vais pas vous avez des paroles qui
m'appartiennent pas qui sont les vôtres
et des lobbys ses gains lundi
oui lobby oui j'aime les pays chauds
tout cas les choix de vie entre
l'afrique et les caraïbes
est ce que tu peux me citer un nom des
nuls non des nues les bains comme j'ai
pas canal excusez moi que j'ai plus de
voix non c'est parce que j'ai plus de
voix jean pascal
pascal légitimus et puis bourg dont il
connaît bien et puis et bernard combes
par une question à l'opposé ils sont sur
le plateau ce soir ici font de leur
argent alors dominique lui s'achète de
la drogue
alain il me répond d'un alain va aux
[ __ ] et chantal vient de changer son
stérilet voilà
je ne dirais pas des fois il est bien
ouais non mais là il aurait pu être
beaucoup plus méchant est vrai que
j'étais mieux messieurs farrugia elle
est là je viens contente il est très
gentil alors là je voudrais tordre le
cou à une légende
une légende qui dit que monsieur fabrice
vial et drôle que quand il a pris de la
cocaïne
c'est une qualité dont j'ai arrêté il ya
deux ans aux pulsions 2 tenez moi je me
souviens je trouve leurs envies dernier
un vendredi 17 à 11 heures du matin il
avait rien dans le nez et il a dit je
mangerais bien 300 ch au poil au dos
c'est pas mal non plus un gramme de coke
pour nous faire rigoler soit lemay h3c
pression
dis moi que je me trompe j'ai lu un
article où il disait que tu es né à
vichy
c'est vrai dans l'allier c'est vrai
ouais mon père et mon père musicien
ouais et il était chef d'orchestre au au
casino de vichy et puis là-bas il est en
saison là bas il a fait juin juillet ou
de septembre finale de septembre c'est
christophe willem le alors mon papa dont
10 mois et c'est vrai que tu as été
conçue sur le bateau qui revenait
d'afrique du nord ag je sais pas où ils
ont fait ça parce qu'ils m'ont on peut
parler mais je devais pas en veux pas
être poindre dans un moment pareil dans
un moment pareil ça mais le coeur aux
galipettes des parents s'étaient pas sur
le banc alors parce que mon père de la
deep arrivés à bord d'algérie mais mais
ils ont dû faire ça à marseille
ouais alors tu effectivement issu d'une
longue lignée de musiciens puisque ton
grand père dirige l orchestre
philharmonique de tunis il a fait ouais
il a fait des il a fait des choses comme
ça tu dises il a dirigé des orchestres
il était premier basson alors qu'est ce
qui les rend in de tunis
il était à la salle maltaise à quelqu'un
de très important
ton père avait un orchestre à alger
ouais qui marchait très bien ce qu'il a
fait danser dans ses rangs un phare au
dialogue est de bon ton oncle était chef
d'orchestre de mireille mathieu c'est
vrai c'est vrai dans les années 70 et la
première fois que tu as vu mireille
mathieu ça t'as fait quoi
ben je sais plus j'étais trop petit puis
après ils ont pour montrer ce que j'ai
plus rien
et puis il ya les violer tu as appris la
flûte
ouais la flûte traversière c'est vrai
c'est comment des flûtes traversières je
joue comme ça c'est le foot c'est comme
une petite poussée qu'elle serait
d'accord et puis tu es devenu batteur de
rock
ouais c'était parce que je voulais
devenir de rock'n'roll ouais et alors
bah voilà ce que je fais maintenant on
doit annoncer par hé ouais non mais
c'était vous l'êtes
je me suis dit que peut-être je voulais
faire vedette et puis comme la batterie
ça me plaisait bien plus que c'était
bien et puis comme j'ai toujours aidé un
regret de rien ça se trouve indochine
ils sont même pas drôle
comme j'étais déjà un peu gros c'était
bien ça a aidé pour draguer un peu quoi
donc tirer un peu moins sur l'élastique
quand même hélas la chanson ça te tente
toujours une question pour lui c'est
chanter je sais chanter mais voir qu'est
ce que tout change pas important je
t'attendrai à la porte du garage tue pas
les trois principales bretons papa il
faut la nuit mais malgré l'éclairage
pour appeler le puits nous pourrons voir
jusqu'au fond du secret
david ferrer
ouais hein dis moi donc tu t'es retrouvé
je sais pas comment en train de faire
les bandes-annonces de canal+ toi je
suis rentré j'étais je suis entré à
canal en outre 84 g/t rtl d'abord
j'étais de standardiste puis après j'ai
bossé avec max meynier voyez les
routiers sont sympas et max dans sa
grande bonté m'a fait rencontrer
dominique cantien je suis devenue
assistante dominique cantien puis de fil
en aiguille j'ai fait des bons enfants
un fils en aiguille fidèles et hui et la
tension est là tu es devenu je suis
devenu
ouais parce que j'ai pas arrêté
cherchiez et pourquoi c'est toujours toi
qu'il parlera dans l'interview
je n'en sais rien parce que je suis un
chercheur et qu il est intelligent ça
les énerve que tu parles toujours
maintenant ils s'en foutent c'est bien
mais c'est bien bien y penser moi je
parle d'accord sur les repose chez
durand waie tué a dit on et quand tu dis
des trucs mal et on est les anciens
nouveaux comics je veux pas lui fait
remarquer qu'il dit des trucs comme ça
quand même
on est d'accord mais si on est des
anciens nouveaux comiques s'est endettée
nouveaux colis que les anciennes
ouais les inconnus c'est des
révolutionnaires j'ai lu dans le journal
ont séparé ces services ont fusé moi de
vous interrompre non parce que là on est
je suis de 7 dt mois
ouais mon comité d'entreprise la
boucherie chevaline on est aussi né tout
bon
me permet d'interrompre aussi c'est tout
bête mais ça va prendre cinq minutes à
moi je m'étonnais des trembles h est
venu voir parce que j'aime bien les
inconnus moi j'aime bien ce que vous
faites un c'est formidable qu'isabelle
un double puis là je voyais des
personnes d'obédience judaïque ça nous
fait un point commun ce monsieur dans le
show-business fabre f non je suis tombé
qu'une personne les personnes de couleur
là je vois seulement je la presse par
semaine telles données vous avez un
droit que vous n'êtes pas pauline jeu
c'est moche de latitude que vous avez tu
de moi
ben voilà tout ce barouf ont tendance à
l'habitude moi et tous respectent la loi
mère au salon ouais t'es un beau [ __ ]
quoi tu dis ça devant le char de thon
rouge 17/20 inattendu qu'on dit qu'on ne
tue pas du phoque à la nativité
je m'intègre maison avec tout le respect
qu'elle vaudois cet hôtel est tellement
vous empilez je vais pas m'en excuser
moi non pas ses ventes reculer laurent
bateau de monde que ça j'essaie
d'arrêter non merci je n'aurais pas dû
me payant veut pas de moi c'est toi
j'étais des mois tout le respect que je
vous dois je m'appelle jean pantaloni je
prends une bête suis pas un animal mais
bon on au splendid de partir de renault
splendide il ya partir du corps je ne
sais pas je te connais pas va pas être
content à partir donc à partir de
maintenant 1 à 22 heures tous les soirs
et non à la vente est censé être un
comique fin tu veux bosser là dedans
obama est vrai que pour moi ça n'a pas
toujours été facile on veut te voir un
bon déjà bon ben je suis né dans une
banlieue un petit peu quelques branches
étaient difficiles
inquiétude m'en sortir il ya eu cet état
d'un bond de petite fille je connais le
bullet façon j'ai payé tu dis moi et
tout le respect que je vous dois vous
étiez vous en sortir par le biais de
l'expression théâtrale ont fait des
pardons de la petite fille
donc c'est une vieille histoire études
moi c'est moi qu'est ce que tu fais de
remuer le passé
1 enfin bon bref bon ben aujourd'hui
c'était juste pour mettre 10 ans
un point pour la cfdt les parce que moi
je suis le cndd bon on a il y en a des
problèmes
bon ben on a des le monde tous les
travailleurs salariés dans la boucherie
chevaline ça va pas nous moi je moi je
suis dans la couille de dauphin la
tétine de chat on a des problèmes
bon tu sais tout simplement on est venu
juste pour ça c'est tout pas si on sait
que l'émission est en direct ne se sera
pas coupée à ça c'est pas besoin de vous
et je vous remercie de l'émission là-bas
merci à tous les abus et comment
d'accord bomba après tout le service
public est ouvert à tout le monde le
service public c'est la télévision du
public qui est bien là j'ai lancé ses
cryptes et donc les mets qui passe pour
un tout le monde peut s'exprimer
la preuve la preuve jamais fait
jamais jamais jamais donc tu va essuyer
les plâtres un petit peu d'une certaine
façon
mesdames et messieurs je vous demande un
petit peu de silence voici l'interview
corbeau abbas et du silence alors la
table corbeau première question qui
chantent en playback beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup qui chantent en playback
j'ai vu un village chanteur direct et
avec des chanteurs
jamais vu plastic bertrand mais je sais
plus s'il travaille pas qui n'écrit pas
ses livres paul loup sulitzer bonnes
réponses qui ne lit pas les livres dont
ils parlent
ppda s'est bien trouvé ça qui fait des
ménages qui fait des ménages
gérard holtz parce que je lis interview
très bien qui ne répond aux interviews
qu'en différé
fidel castro avec ppda a rien qui en
prend du road jacquot qui est [ __ ] en
[ __ ] si je les cite tout cela parce
qu'il me l'a dit moi qui ai pas [ __ ] de
quoi y en a quatre ici qui tuerait sa
mère pour réussir mois et arthur qui est
l'info j'en ai jamais rencontrées dans
le métier si on a une qu'il m'appelle
toi et articles qui en parle beaucoup il
fait pas grand-chose droit way qui ne
fait aucune pub en france mais on tourne
à l'étranger ce n'est à la halle aux
houblons il n'en avait jamais ici moi
j'ai vu des trucs sur le cognac
je comprenais pas la marque un succès ça
japonais qui est radin ppda j'ai bossé
avec l'humain ouais
qui a tué le petit grégory a put ainsi
je le dis non il me tue un titre nba le
terrain j'ai commis la boulette
étudiants
en continu atavique en vo qui trichent
sur son âge chantal tu as quel âge
chantal chantal elle a plus de 20 ans ah
oui et qui a tort de rester fâché avec
son couturier
oh [ __ ] il a pas mal dé tous les
comiques sont mal habillés et le plus
c'est la gaffe avec le costard c'est
monstrueux comique ni connu autant pour
moi qui ai d un plan celui qui lui
passait livre qui sourit avec l'aide
intégrale de son 1000e dentiste le
pauvre il travaille puis maintenant hâte
et patrick mais on y voit pub mais il
paraît qu'il revient en mars avec un
nouveau concept ray qu'est-ce qu'on en a
à [ __ ] ça va pas le faire je suis
super fait pas senti super bien patrick
boisvert depuis un an
mais là vous êtes sûr ça use donc
oubliez moi est d'accord mais super bien
joué
le public est formidable qui s'est fait
refaire le même jacques martin ah oui
c'est vrai qu'ils trichent sur sa date
de naissance avec un listing piane chéri
ah bon pourquoi est ce que je fais
en fait elle ne dit pas qu'elle a triché
avec un lifting elle dit qu'elle s'est
offert le nez et les gens avec changer
ça n'a pas vraiment mais qu'est-ce que
ça d'extraordinaire à rien on sera me
demande moi qui est gaucher
[Musique]
je me suis pas fait branler pas
raccrocher jamais tu ne connais pas de
gaucher mais j'en connais pas non non
j'en connais très peu c'est vrai nous
ôtera riego c'est quoi doucher
contrarier moi je suis chantal et moi on
est à gauche et contraint ben ouais mais
c'est peut-être pas un handicap d'être
gaucher bas on est super bon baby on
joue bien des domaines
y'a pas que va dire regarde prendront
part les téléviseurs les regards un
homme sur dix vit sa vie à l'envers
un homme sur dix se résigne à subir ces
conditions de gauche est dans un monde
de droitiers on savait déjà que les
gauchers étaient de redoutables
adversaires dans les compétitions
sportives
mais saviez-vous qu'une étude
scientifique anglaise des plus sérieuses
vient d'être réalisée sur leur sexualité
pendant six mois
150 gaucher et 150 droitier tous sexes
confondus ont subi une série de tests
les gauchers se sont révélés
sexuellement plus performants qui en est
ressorti en conclusion c'est que sur les
300 cas étudiés la totalité des gauchers
ont eu un acte sexuel qualifiée de
normale avec quelques cas classés très
satisfaisant en revanche ce qui concerne
le score les droitiers il a été qualifié
de plus modestes avec notamment cinq cas
classés insatisfaisant pascal de crem
sexologue confirme les conclusions de
cette étude
l'explication se situe selon lui au
niveau des hémisphères du cerveau chez
le droitier cilmi sphère gauche le plus
développé inversement
or il se trouve que le centre principal
de stimulation de l'érection
tu trouves située dans l'hémisphère
droit et comme c'est l'hémisphère qui
génétiquement supérieur chez le boucher
saha explique tout à fait le résultat
des études que qui ont été réalisés
léonard de vinci beto et jimi hendrix
sont des gauchers célèbres et est il
pour autant plus performants
sexuellement
michel gareau historiens s'est penché
sur la question
personnage commune et de citer je ne
peux pas m'engager mais ce que je peux
vous dire c'est que les chroniqueurs la
cour du roi louis 15 rapporte que les
dames galantes affiché une certaine
préférence pour les chevaliers gauche et
d'ailleurs dans les campagnes le gaucher
qui était considéré comme un être de
malédiction on faisait l'objet de
convoitises assidue de la part des
villageoises les gauchers sont
sexuellement plus performant est-ce de
l'info est de l'intox je vous le demande
un peu à vous aussi d'ailleurs alain
chabat c'est de l'intox c'est de l'intox
c'est de l'intox
qu'est ce qui te fait dire ça à mon
petit jeu c'est pas un type j'ai
l'impression qu'il veut
comédien qu'il y avait un truc j'ai pas
les lunettes peut-être way quelque chose
et avaient l'air fou ce que tu fais la
vodka tonic c'est possible oui oh là là
là là je suis là non mais c'est pas vrai
oh non laurent on le paie il faut bien
qu'ils aient passé entre eux
nous pensons à toi face aux infos
pourquoi tu as une expérience avec un
parce que je suis une ancienne gauchère
c'est de l'intox une ancienne bon je
suis sans quoi c'est de l'intox
j'y crois pas et puis comme il dit ah
non je crois pas là c'est de l'intox sur
pas 50%
ouais ya 50% de chance que ça soit de
l'intox
alors c'était un sujet qui vous a été
envoyé par monsieur maurice ou groupe
entame à gagner alors il a gagné 2000
francs voilà ça des gens fait maintenant
été tirés à la raison est ce que pour
savoir si je mets mille balles de ma
poche
qu'est-ce qu'on écoute corti on regarde
la réponse et ouais c'est la boxe c'est
complètement fou je travaille pas à
l'insee le rapport du bidon en tout cas
qui est vrai c'est que moi je suis
gaucher etc entre nous j'aimerais bien
vous propagé la rumeur qui dit que nous
les gauchers on est les meilleurs
ça m'arrangerait bien les affaires
auprès des filles
or nous
je laissais le comédien se passe pas pas
du tout je promets toi tu as rien toi
rien toi et j'avais dit la bonne réponse
avait dit que c est bien le score final
philippe corti avec côté les gauchers
que les problèmes d'érection qui sont de
couleur ont été fatales ce sera chacun
leur vie par contre tirs au but entre
farrugia
guaino
sa venue à québec et non
je faisais une question à tous les deux
vous allez me dire si c'est de l'info de
l'intox s'agit d'un roi du rire jean
roucas
ouais j'en s'appelle roucas car c'est le
nom du quartier de marseille où il a
grandi un pinceau un fou bravo à tous
les deux c'était de l'art
encore un roi du rire avec vous c'est
normal la glycine
yes s'il s'appelle sim parce qu'il
faisait la moitié du poids de son oncle
simon intox info c'est lui qui a gagné
breux
mais le siècle vivant
il est très content assure la ca s'élève
aujourd'hui à l'ordre pour tout à
l'heure
je vais
je n'avais pas fait c'est sûr
bon bon
r tout est
[Musique]
dis moi gérard ya une question que je
voulais te poser quand même pourquoi tu
débarques toujours les émissions de télé
là tu débarques chez dechavanne là ce
soir tu es j'ai débarqué dans mon
émission qu est-ce qui c'est quoi cette
histoire c'est le deuxième fois je
voudrais pas devenir le spécialiste de
ce genre de chose en général disons que
c'est par par solidarité la première
phase tpo
lorsqu'elle est cette espèce de
nazillons visio nice tu es là ce soir
c'est quoi j'ai pas compris la nouvelle
à ce soir c'est comme ça une couleur une
rue envie de niveau anti chez toi tu
regarde la télé puis d'un seul coup tu
t'habitues prends ta bagnole et tu viens
pas de façon systématique mais voilà
c'est la deuxième fois bon écoute
maintenant c'est à moi de te confessé
oui ça te va comme réponse sous 12h
samba oui qu'est ce que tu fais une
saison
c'était spontané c'est un acte ça se
finit bien sûr vu c'est une pulsion est
ce que tu es favorable divorce
oui
ce qui serait une femme avec deux trois
ans quand j'ai quitté une femme avec un
enfant qui penche dès fois a toujours
oui oui j'y pense que la vie ne lui
empêche pas de les revoir et de devoir
élever ma fille bon je me suis marié je
divorce et l'euthanasie tu serais
d'accord
dans l'absolu on dans l'absolu oui pour
avoir été confronté à deux trois cas
comme ça désespérer totalement oui
désespéré donc oui mais c'est un
problème très délicat de suicide
oui oui il n'ya pas commenter le suicide
je pensais être suicidé toi
non pas vraiment mais pour les autres ça
te fait pas peur il n'y a pas de pas de
peur à avoir pour les autres je pense
qu'on est
je pense que c'est aussi une certaine
façon une certaine façon à donner un
prix à sa vie que se suicider c'est une
espèce d'ul qui me pouvoir qu'on l'a de
vie et de mort de sa propre vie de sa
propre mort je vais ouais je rentrais
est-ce que tu est favorable à la peine
de mort non pas du tout je suis contre
la peine de mort et surtout en chêne
pendant dix ans mais si ta fille on vous
avez quelque chose à ton enfant et tout
ça je suis contre la peine de mort même
les assassins enfants même pour les
assassins d'enfants et d'une façon un
peu plus anecdotique je pense que je ne
pourrai jamais partagé une seule idée de
de le pen donc à partir du moment où il
est à ce point
pour la peine de mort même si j'étais
totalement ignorante de ce sujet même si
cela ne concernait pas je serai de
systématiquement opposés parce qu'ils
pensent le contraire et c'est très clair
tout ceci est dit favorable à la
légalisation des drogues douces wii
board où ça veut dire quoi herbe chiite
tout ça maintenant je sais pas s'il est
totalement d'accord pour enfin bon
oui je pense que ça changera pas trop le
problème il ya ya ya ya un certain
nombre d'exemples lalal hollande
l'espagne
quelques pays comme ça ça n'a pas trop
bouleversé le paysage politique j'allais
dire de ces pays
tu crois en dieu oui ce sera le moment
j'essaie de vivre ça au quotidien
c'est à dire que je ne suis pas
pratiquant je suis je suis juif au cas
où tu ne le serait encore pas donc je ne
suis pas pratiquant mais plutôt que
d'attendre des fêtes qui ou pardonne
nous et ça vous colle aux caisses
j'essaie eux au quotidien de de
comprendre d'être le mois
banal et médiocre possible et de donner
un maximum
c'est de la façon dont elles à moi d'y
croire tu crois au diable bah oui une
vérité une contre vérité
certainement ja oui oui l'equilibre un
ton avis quelle forme il prend le diable
aujourd'hui tout tout ce qu'on est en
train de faire est diabolique
la conception de de cette émission et
des reliques
oh
[Musique]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous y mettez un peu
de bleu